Gold is a priceless or pointless one of
the original forms of money sparking
Wars treasure hunts and love affairs but
for today's investors gold may have lost
its luster are the recent booms and
busts in gold just a market cycle or
change in human appetites so here's the
situation gold is a time-honored haven
for financial storms it's an echo
chamber for anxieties about the economy
fears about global conflict and guesses
about the whims of central bankers the
2008 financial crisis sent investors
leaping to the safety of the precious
metal rocket and gold to a record 1921
dollars an ounce in 2011 that made gold
one of the best investments in the world
over a 12-year run then as economic
growth returned and stock markets
rallied the metal began to tumble
investors dumped gold starting in 2013
at times of unrest and instability the
appeal of the metal spikes up still the
gold price remains far from its peak now
here's the argument gold bears say there
are fewer reasons to own gold now
because they see the global economy
recovering a strong dollar and the
prospect of higher US interest rates
makes it less attractive that is
legendary investor Warren Buffett points
out gold isn't productive and only Rises
when investors believe that the right
the fearful will grow but bulls say
long-term global economic growth is far
from certain and the supply of gold may
be near repeat the following years of
declining investment in Mines ultimately
Gold's future hinges on the hopes and
fears of investors